[Music]
our speaker tonight Adrienne mayor has
written about a list of topics so
fascinating that it sort of makes you
question your life choices she was a
fellow at cosmos last year and is back
at Stanford this year as a research
scholar one of the unfortunate side
effects of a short term mindset is
thinking that everything around you is a
new idea on earth for the first time
tonight's speaker will show us that
concepts we often associate with the
late 20th century have deep historical
antecedents that often go back thousands
of years
a true long now undertaking if I've seen
one give a round of applause for
Adrienne mayor thanks everybody what an
honor to be invited to the interval just
perfect place to tell some of the first
science fiction stories here's my
clicker I'm gonna move this a little bit
a bit about myself I'm a historian of
ancient science and so I investigate the
crossroads between classical Greek myth
archaeology history art I'm interested
in uncovering nuggets of historical and
scientific realities that are embedded
in mythology and ancient writings so you
could say I'm a historian of ancient
curiosity I'm seeking the first Inklings
of the scientific impulse for my book
gods and robots I asked who first
imagined robots automatons self-moving
devices most historians would trace the
first automatons of the Middle Ages with
the clockwork mechanisms but I wondered
could the ideas the concepts of
automatons creating animated statues and
self moving devices could those ideas
have been imagined long before the tech
ecology existed made them possible and I
should warn you that some philosophers
of science actually claim no one in
antiquity could imagine automatons until
the technology already existed they're
misinformed
where does innovation come from if it
doesn't come from imagining what doesn't
already exist and it turns out that as
early as the time of Homer more than
2,500 years ago the Greeks were
imagining now in myth how one might
fabricate artificial life cell home
devices animated beings artificial
beings these entities were always
described as products of technology I'm
not talking about lifeless objects or
inert matter that's brought to life by a
magical spell or just a God's command
the process that the Greeks imagined for
these entities could be called biotech
may ancient Greek for life through
crafts that's the root of our word
biotechnology now automatons that were
that were always described as made not
born manufactured not reproduced
biologically appeared in some myths that
I think you're all probably pretty
familiar with you're just not used to
looking for automatons in them so I'm
going to be talking about Jason and the
Argonauts the fire bringer Prometheus
and Pandora these remarkable tales about
creating artificial life were ancient
thought experiments about what could be
achieved if only you had the creativity
and the powers of a god or the gods and
I should add these myths were taken
seriously by philosophers and
playwrights in antiquity as ways to
think about trying to imitate improve or
surpass nature and what's interesting
for us tonight is that they foreshadow
some of the doubts and fears that
robotics and AI technology that we're
facing today one rising anxiety today is
the potential for
totalitarian improv oppression
maybe you some of you read the article
by Yuval her re why technology favors
tyranny he predicted AI will empower
human tyrants to impose ever greater
totalitarianism with ever greater ease
now that association between technology
and tyranny that might seem like a very
modern concept but I'm here to tell you
tonight that it's a very old story I
found that Greek myths about artificial
life they have a striking feature in
common all of the automatons and
self-moving devices are deployed by
those with supreme power either gods
like Zeus or Kings so as early as homer
and we're talking about 750 650 BC
people were imagining robotic servants
lifelike replicas of humans and animals
and even AI and most of these were made
by Hephaestus the god of technology and
invention is the only god with a job
he's the only God who sweats
he's always shown at work in his forties
a blacksmith and he has wonderful powers
he has a brilliant resume of techno
marvels Homer's Iliad describes how her
Festus constructed a set of automatic
bellows for his Forge these bellows
could blow or blast air according to his
needs in his Forge so he didn't he
didn't need to adjust them they could
and anticipate what he needed a Festus
also built a set of automatic gates for
the heavens so that they could open and
close at the approach of the Gods
chariots the first automated garage door
as he might
I don't want to draw any direct lines
from antiquity to today's innovations
but you just can't help thinking of
these things next he fabricated a fleet
of self-driving delivery carts that they
brought nectar and ambrosia to the gods
banquets and then they returned when
they were empty now I thought I think
his most amazing invention was the crew
of female androids made of gold I wish I
had an ancient picture of them these
will have to do they served as his
personal assistants and they moved
around efficiently to and fro in his in
his workshop Homer describes these
golden maidens as he says that they
looked like real young women just like
real young women and they were endowed
with strength reason and mind but even
more mind-blowing he says they were
equipped with all the knowledge of the
gods all the knowledge of the gods
that's quite a data dump I mean you no
need that much you don't need that much
knowledge but who knows you never know
you might but it does make you think of
a mythical version of AI these were
labor-saving devices that intelligent
machines and they were all made for the
benefit of the gods and goddesses and
when they're confined to the realm of
the heavens Hephaestus inventions
they're benign they're charming they're
harmless but when such things are sent
down to earth that's when the trouble
starts violence and suffering follow
let's consider the fate of Prometheus
I'm sure you all remember he stole
divine fire a technology of fire to help
human beings and in the myth Zeus the
all-powerful king of gods and men was a
vindictive tyrant to punish Prometheus
he chained him to a mountain and then he
ordered her Festus and we hear that it
was against Hephaestus Azul but he was
ordered to do this to forge a bronze
eagle to torment
Prometheus and Zeus's eagle was imagined
as a metallic Raptor that arrived like
clockwork each day almost drone like in
the argonautica the the epic poem of
jason and the argonauts the sailors
observe the eagles machine like
movements and I'll just quote from the
argonautica each afternoon the gleaming
eagle flew over our ship with a loud
roaring noise and we saw how the
feathers of each wing rose and fell
moved up and down like a bank of
polished oars Mizzou's of course always
aa really vindictive he took vicious
revenge on humankind for accepting the
gift of stolen fire he commanded a
Festus to construct a ravishing and
seductive artificial young woman and
Zeus's specifications were this should
be evil
disguised as beauty and you all know who
it was it was Pandora probably not the
Pandora of the fairy tales of your youth
she was not just an innocent young woman
poets described this female Android as
made not born so she's a technological
product she was to be sent to earth with
a sealed jar that was filled with
misfortunes and suffering to plague
humans for eternity and in the myth here
we see a vase painting of Zeus admiring
Pandora before he sends down to earth
and in the myth we hear that Zeus took
sadistic gleam in his plan it was said
that he laughed out loud as he admired
Pandora his gift for Humanity so she was
really a fembot with one mission on
earth to insinuate herself into human
society and then release unseal that jar
the swarm of evils would then come out
and play humankind for ever and Zeus
ordered his messenger Hermes
- escort Pandora to earth there's an
interesting vase painting I don't have a
picture of it but it shows Zeus and
Hermes exchanging a sly smile as they
are about to inflict Pandora on on earth
well Hermes took Pandora down to earth
and gave her as a bride to a
happy-go-lucky guy named Epimetheus
Epimetheus was Prometheus's brother and
prometheus warned Epimetheus not to
accept the dangerous gift from zoos but
Epimetheus was dazzled by Pandora he
went for the short-term gains and we
hear from the poets only later did he
realize his terrible error after she
opened the jar and I just want to point
out the name prometheus in ancient Greek
it means forethought looking ahead and
Epimetheus it means hindsight Epimetheus
is the perfect Patsy for Zeus is cruel
this is a very famous vase showing
Pandora being prepared for her mission
and the artist you can see all that all
the other figures are really moving
around they're active Pandora standing
there stiffly like I sort of statue or a
doll she has an uncanny smile on her
face as she's being prepared for her
assignment on earth and here's a
close-up of that
I think Pandora's kind of eerily similar
to the evil robot Maria in the great
silent film metropolis if you haven't
seen it I highly recommend this film
it's 1927 silent film it was made just a
few years after the invention of the
word robot and already in 1927
people were imagining a future techno
dystopia where the rich ruling class
oppressed the miserable workers with
automation and robots now in the Greek
myths as I noted how Festus Ezeli
Moten's are harmless as long as it
confined to the
the God so these stories seem to be
telling us that intelligent machines
like self moving carts and the golden
servants they're good to imagine as
thought experiments but the myths imply
that such things can be pretty dangerous
and destructive in the real world of
humans now
another ancient myth tells how
Hephaestus forged the first bronze robot
and I can't resist showing Ray
Harryhausen's fabulous image of tell us
that the giant bronze robot the the
automaton was called Talos and it was
made for King Minos who ruled Crete with
an iron hand so tell us was a killer
robot
he was intended to defend the island
kingdom of King Minos and he was
programmed to spot strangers spot anyone
coming ashore and actually could pick up
and hurl boulders at ships to sink them
and the coins of ancient Crete boasted
about that that capability of Talos now
should anyone make it ashore in close
combat this bronze robot could heat his
body red-hot grabbed up a victim hug him
to his chest and roast them alive and
this mirror shows that capability so
tell us was imagined as a kind of cyborg
half-human half-machine he's able to
carry out complex activities and he fits
the definition of robot in a way because
he we know details about his inner
workings and he even has a power source
tell us we're told has a single tube or
a conduit that went from his head to his
feet and in that tube or conduit pulsed
I Corps I Corps is the life fluid of the
immortal gods that's his power source
the entire Vivid system if you will was
sea sealed the whole system was sealed
with a bra
Boult on his ankle it's his weak point
when they dropped anchor in crete jason
and the argonauts it looked like they
were doomed to be tell us as next
victims but luckily for them they had
the sorceress Medea along with them and
she figured out how to destroy tell us
she realized that if you removed the
bronze bolt in the robot's ankle his
power source would drain out an ancient
Greek vase paintings that from 2,500
years ago showed Jason
using a tool to remove the bolt this is
an example this power source I Corps
then we're told flowed out like molten
lead it's a kind of technological
description the great robot of King
Minos toppled over and expired so not
only was tellus created with technology
but he was taken down with technology
technology was required to dismantle him
and it's interesting that the ancient
Greek artists really emphasized this
sort of human-like traits of this bronze
machine and and his unfair death I mean
after all he's killed just while he's
doing his job right he's doing his job
for the tyrant king and if you look
closely at this base pinning you can see
that the artist has painted a teardrop
on the robots cheek kind of reminds you
of how the death of Hal in 2001 Medea
also figured out how to overcome yet
another set of deadly automatons forged
by Hephaestus for yet another king who
wanted Jason dead this king ordered
Jason to carry out two impossible tasks
first he had to yoke a pair of bronze
fire-breathing bulls and then plow a
field with these animated bronze oxen
and then he had to defeat the invincible
army of robot like warriors that would
spring up from the plowed
field and the evil king was confident
that if even if Jason could somehow
avoid being burned to death by the Robo
Bulls he and his men would be
slaughtered by the armed androids
springing up from the field
well Medea created a special drug to
give Jason superpowers to wrangle the
bronze bulls so he could plow that field
without being incinerated and then at
nightfall the dreadful warriors in
bronze armor began to emerge from that
ploughed field this is a medieval image
but I think it's pretty good techno
wizard Medea to the rescue again
now Medea you really want her on your
side if you're gonna be facing these
automatons
she's an ancient hacker she figures out
the vulnerable points the weak points
and she explains them she knew that
those automatons are unnatural soldiers
were essentially hardwired to attack she
cleverly hacked the coding imprinted in
the soldiers what she did she told Jason
to throw some stones into into their
midst into their ranks and that would
trigger a fatal domino effect a sort of
cascade effect they would sense the
blows on their shields and then they
turn immediately to the the person
closest to them and they turn on each
other in a frenzy confusion ensues and
then Jason and the Argonauts can rush in
and finish them off and they escape the
evil Kings plot well notice that in all
of these myths the machines of MELAS
belong to tyrannical rulers whether it's
Zeus or mythical Kings they used
automatons to wield absolute power to
torture or to kill so was this use of
bio technique is it only an imaginary
feature of cruel tyrants in mythology
what about real life what about the real
world did any actual tyrants deploy real
automatons and machines in historical
times yes they did in fact
the autocratic fascination with
automatons as instruments of power was
not just a theme in the classical myths
like their counterparts in the myths the
autocratic rulers many of them I found
quite a few examples commissioned
animated statues and machines to inflict
pain and death and this was documented
as early as the 6th century BC and I
don't know if I should give a trigger
warning some of these stories a pretty
grim
the first example historical example
involves a fiery bronze bull to
incinerate victims now was it inspired
by the bronze to robot talents heating
his body red hot or maybe the
fire-breathing bulls in the method
that's unknown this particular deadly
bronze bull belonged to the cold blooded
tyrant named phalaris of Sicily and he
became absolute dictator of the island
in 578 BC during his reign of terror
a brilliant sculptor named perilous
presented King phalaris with the statue
of a bull so true to life it seemed to
breathe now I want to note here that
ancient artists were capable of making
incredibly realistic sculptures of
people and animals these are all real
examples of bronze statues from
antiquity the inlaid eyes and pupils
inlaid fingernails teeth and even
eyelashes and remember they they work
just bronze like these they were painted
realistically with natural
natural-looking paint that actually
contained wax in the pigment so that
they really looked real some of them
were animated some could blink they
could turn their heads they could move
their arms and some could make sounds
para Laius the craftsman explained to
the king that this hollow bronze bowl
was a torture device just locks I went
inside and built a fire under it as the
bull's body
sup the man roast to death he said
perilous then described the fiendish
system of tubes that he had installed in
the Bulls interior and these tubes
directed smoke and flames to come out of
the bull's nostrils and the pipes
amplified the victim shrieks through the
Bulls mouth it gave the impression of a
real bellowing fire-breathing bull like
those in the myth of jason and the
argonauts and the statue is essentially
animated by the human being trapped
inside and the apparatus inside King was
impressed he asked for a demonstration
as soon as perilous crawled inside to
yell into the pipes phalaris locked the
trapdoor and roasted his first victim
and there would be many more now
phalaris was detested for his brutality
and this story is told by many
historians many of them actually saw the
bull afterwards so it really did exist
he was detested for his brutality he was
finally overthrown after about 20 years
but that diabolical bronze bull lived on
not just in in stories but physically
more than 300 years later during the
First Punic War between Rome and
Carthage
Hannibal's father Hamilcar Barca invaded
Sicily during the Punic First Punic War
he plundered the treasures of Sicily and
one of his prizes was the notorious
bronze bull he shipped it to Carthage
across the Mediterranean into Tunisia
the bull remained in Carthage for
another hundred years now we can only
guess how the bull served the rulers of
Carthage but I will remind you that the
Carthaginians were reported to sacrifice
their children in a furnace shaped like
their God when the Roman general skippy
Oh finally defeated Carthage 146 BC he
recovered the the bronze bowl and he
shipped it back to Sicily
he set it up as a monument he said to
the viciousness of tyrants like phalaris
the messages trust the Romans and you
won't have any more tyrants like this
the sculptor Peres Laius was also
castigated for using his skills to make
such a project for a tyrant phalaris
sorry to say was not the only malicious
ruler to own a realistic statue that was
brought to life by the screams of the
burning victim sicily it turns out was a
hotbed of such devices there were many
others
another Sicilian King burned people
inside a giant bronze statue of a man
yet another King in Sicily had a
realistic bronze stallion that he used
for the same purposes and these kings
were known to offer rewards to artisans
and inventors for making novel torture
machines and now I just want to point
out that novel machines of war were also
rewarded by powerful kings in 400 BC the
tyrant Dionysius of Syracuse Sicily
again invited inventors to a contest to
make advanced weapons and that
competition is what resulted in the
first mechanized catapults taking
warfare to new levels of killing rewards
and prizes started attracting military
engineers and inventors to the courts of
philip ii of macedonia Alexander's
father demetrius poly or cts also of
macedonia and mithra daddy's the great
of Pontus the brilliant scientist
Archimedes also devised many ingenious
war machines for Sicily you can see an
example there on the on the on the right
lower right of a giant claw that would
pick up ships and sink them and so while
military engineers were developing
crossbow artillery and powerful torsion
catapults in the 4th and 3rd centuries
other engineers and inventors were
flocking to Alexandria Egypt Alexandria
Egypt at that time was the Silicon
Valley of antiquity that had the museum
the library and inventors actually
designed and constructed a great variety
of self moving devices self-driving
theaters complex automaton some of the
miniature some of them colossal using
mechanics and they even had plans to use
magnetism king ptolemy ii of alexandria
commissioned their most advanced designs
for his magnificent spectacles in
alexandria his grand procession of 279
BC it was a just an outrageous parade of
stunning engineering marvels that wound
through the streets for days you can see
the the streets of Alexander Alexandria
in this lower lower right here and there
were many monumental life like animated
statues of gods and goddesses
each on carts pulled by 300 men on one
cart for example set a colossal 15-foot
tall goddess she was dressed in real
silk clothing sitting there regally on
her throne and then periodically along
the route of the parade this automaton
stood up poured a jug of milk into a
large bowl and then sat down again all a
very stately manner of course during his
reign King Ptolemy executed many members
of his family and his political enemies
he declared himself a god but his
automatons as far as we know were
nonviolent
so those grandiose spectacles of
technology were intended to drive home
his godlike absolute power well history
records another dictator who
demonstrated his iron rule in another
parade with another giant self moving
automata
after the Macedonians crushed democratic
Athens they set up the brutal tyrant
Demetrius to rule the city he destroyed
the democracy and he commissioned a
giant animatronic snail now I hear that
someone here who has a snail that he
drives around town so what a coincidence
I guess snails were have been automatic
auto meet on snails have been the thing
for centuries millennia he sent this he
set this great snail to crawl at the
head of Athens most sacred procession
and as the realistic giant snail inched
along the route it even used a trail of
slime along the streets now you might
ask why make a giant self-moving
gastropod snails were considered slow
this is how your vehicle work no
probably not
oh this is this is a this is a design
from a engineer in Amsterdam who tried
to figure out how that giant snail moved
but in antiquity snails are considered
slow clumsy lowly creatures to drive
home the insult right behind that giant
snail came a troupe of asses the
grotesque spectacle was a dramatic and
very public way to humiliate the
demoralized defeated citizens of Athens
once so celebrated for their quick
action and intelligence Demetrius what
happened to him he was later expelled
from Athens all 360 of his statues to
himself were smashed and it was reported
that he died of a venomous snake bites
meanwhile in Sparta in 207 BC the
ruthless dictator nabis
seized power the reign of Navis and his
wife a Pegah
was long remembered for extortion
torture and executions of masses of
their subjects a pega was said to far
surpass her husband in cruelty and
murder and maybe that's why Navis
decided to fat fabricator commissioned a
mechanical facsimile of a pega a machine
that resembled the queen with
extraordinary fidelity the robotic
replicas wore a pegas finery and
probably had a lifelike wax or maybe a
plaster cast painted of a pegas own face
now someone on YouTube some engineers
have actually recreated this terrible
device
Navis would summon citizens a citizen of
Sparta ply them with wine to get them
drunk and then demand their money and
their property and if they refused he
would say perhaps my queen a pega will
be more persuasive the man was then
taken to meet the fate fake a pega and
when he reached out and touched her took
her hand the robot stood up triggering
springs to raise her arms which suddenly
grabbed the victim and under her fancy
clothing the body was studded with iron
spikes levers and ratchets tightened a
pegas deadly embrace drawing the victim
closer and driving the spikes deeper and
with a simp a linguistic
many men in sparta after 17 years the
tyrant nabis was finally assassinated
can't help noticing they all come to a
bad end these tyrants
so there's some good news it's often
said that robots fulfill three functions
labor sex and spectacle or entertainment
now the ancient Greeks had those covered
but the examples of automatons in myth
and history also suggest that maybe we
should add power as another function the
drive to dominate and exert power led
tyrants of myth and historical times to
seek and commission nefarious technology
now you at this point you might be
wondering if I cherry picked examples of
the Greek rulers using automatons for
harm or are the myths and if you ask me
later in the Q&A as far as I know there
are two exceptions one from myth and one
from historical times as we saw some of
the historical automatons for inflicting
harm do seem to somehow replicate or
echo elements from the automatons of
myth and I'm thinking of those fiery
bronze bowls and and the bronze robots
tell us is burning embrace kind of a
perversion of a human warmth we can't
really prove which way the causal arrow
goes can't prove that the myths inspired
the tyrants or their engineers but it is
a question that comes to mind it has
been suggested that the spiked animated
figure of a Pegah
and sparta might have inspired the
notorious medieval torture device that
I'm sure you're all thinking of the Iron
Maiden I believe that the Iron Maiden
was never actually made or used but the
idea may well have come from a pega and
we do know that the myth of Talos the
automated bronze guardian of King Minos
that did inspire ideas of robotic
merciless iron Knights in the Middle
Ages and here's Leonardo da Vinci's
model in fact military engineers
continued to be fascinated with the
bronze guardian robot right up to the
present day it's also interesting just
as a side note that security companies
sometimes call themselves tell us I
think
Cisco's security division is called tell
us so they also know the myth in the
1950s the first surface-to-air naval
missiles were named Talos Rockets
consciously after the the myth and
there's cruel irony in the name of the
latest military drones made by elbit
systems to rain death in the Middle East
they're named Hermes after the sly
messenger a trickster messenger of the
sadistic god Zeus who did deliver
Pandora to wreak destruction on mortals
and as we speak Pentagon scientists
working with special ops command and
DARPA are developing a future futuristic
weaponized and AI enhanced exoskeleton
armor for soldiers and they're actively
soliciting designs and ideas from tech
inventors and guess what they named the
suit
tal OS so that they could have the
acronym tell us well in the myths the
tyrant god Zeus simply commanded
Hephaestus to make machines that he used
against humanity in the historical
instances genius craftsmen offered their
work to powerful kings for rewards and
other autocrats held contests much like
DARPA does today and we know that
scientists today are designing AI on
robotic technologies for powerful
corporations the military and for
totalitarian states they present many of
those innovations to the public as only
beneficial such as just examples from
the media lipreading a
GPS location services facial recognition
biometrics surveillance smart lamp posts
like in Hong Kong super soldiers
driverless vehicles and drones but I
know everyone here can imagine darker
purposes well to conclude that might
seem ironic or strange here at the long
now that I'm asking you to time travel
back more than 2700 years but now we do
know that Tech and tyranny have been
linked for millennia which way does the
causal arrow go that's debatable people
have talked about that but I think at
this point it seems like the link itself
might be the more pressing question ai
is advancing a warp speed it's
outstripping our ability to work out the
ethical issues and that unknowable black
box problem of AI seems to loom like
Pandora's a fateful sealed jar if there
is a message from antiquity it seems to
be will we be like short-sighted
Epimetheus who was dazzled by Pandora or
can we be more like Prometheus using our
imagination and foresight to avoid
turning over the future to tyranny in
any form thank you
[Applause]
every one right there we just met a
couple of weeks ago so it's really uh
it's it was really well-timed wonderful
presentation thank you
I had just one thought I don't know I
suspect there's other people out here
staying with the pandora images that I I
never knew that Pandora was a invent
invented crafted creature and I'm kind
of interested in why I didn't know that
whether there's anything there's an
interesting story to be told about how
that figure changed since the fact that
she was invented and the whole thing was
planned from the get-go and it wasn't
her fault
it seems like a significant shift from
the story that I knew and many people
have pointed out that it reminds them of
Eve of course I don't know how I don't
personally know how the story evolved
from antiquity through the Middle Ages
to this fairy tale your European version
that we know but there is a book by
Panofsky and Panofsky called the
evolution of the myth of Pandora so
someone has worked on that problem but
one thing about the myth of Pandora that
really interests me is the is the last
the last thing that's in her jar oh and
it was a jar a sealed jar and antiquity
and a mistranslation and the Renaissance
made it into a box someone missed
translated into box so we think of her
with a box but all the artists show
Pandora reeling back in horror at the
swarm of evils coming out that because
she was such an innocent girl with a
tragic case of curiosity but that's not
the story at all
and the last thing in the Box is
supposed to be hope and all the
fairytale images show hope is a little
fairy who is bringing comfort to
humankind because of all this disaster
that has been unleashed upon the
that's not in the original story either
in antiquity hope was not a good thing
blind hope was philosophers and
playwrights have debated since antiquity
let's hope the worst of the best thing
in Pandora's box and there are even some
ancient artists that show Pandora
personified as a young woman popping up
out of Pandora's jars she's got a
crooked sly smile on her face like she's
mocking you for believing that hope is
gonna help you it's that ambiguity seems
to get to the heart of the whole yeah
the whole problem I mean tonight you see
you just talked about Greek examples in
the book you also talk about examples
from from the east and from other
cultures so it's this is not the only
place that we find this anticipation of
otama to either in myth or in actual
technologies but there does seem to be
something specific about the evolution
of made things in Greece that involves
something you touched on briefly which
is the the power of similitudes
you know the the that this is a moment
if you look at previous at earlier attic
forms of statues or if you look at
Egyptian statues there's an obvious
distance between that and verisimilitude
of the human body and we really see that
in art history and it does seem to be
different so my question is I'm
wondering if you could connect that to
an issue that you do talk about also in
your book that that I think we can all
sort of enjoy today which is this the
uncanny valley absolutely
it seems like the Greeks sort of
discovered the uncanny valley in in
objects in a way maybe that was sort of
original to their artistic exploration
absolutely as I was reading descriptions
in Homer in both the Iliad and the
Odyssey of people encountering very
realistic animated statues living
statues they called them I realized that
all the we think of the uncanny valley
is totally modern it wasn't
I think 1970 by Masahiro mori I think it
is the robotics engineer and what's
interesting is he invented it when he
was looking at prosthetics apparently is
what made him get that uncanny valley
feeling and he identified it then and
extrapolated to robots but Homer
describes Odysseus and various other
characters encountering hyper-realistic
paintings that seem to move and have
sound almost described like movies and
they feel a very disturbed mixed and
ambivalence of absolute fascination sort
of morbid fascination and and awe and it
it's obviously the uncanny valley and if
you think of the slide that I showed of
those hyper-realistic statues think of
them they're life-sized and they're
painted and they are often in temples
and they don't have electric lights so
when you see them they're in a dark
temple maybe lit by maybe outside lit by
moonlight or in the dark or just with an
oil lamp flickering I mean they look
like they're moving and about to breathe
so the uncanny valley sensation goes all
the way back Kentico Bay and not
probably just to Greece there was an
example of a Chinese inventor who
invented an automaton that he showed to
the Emperor and it could move and dance
and act like a regular person and the
Emperor was amused until the automaton
winked at one of his wives and the
Emperor said off with his head and the
inventor immediately said wait wait wait
no it says I made it and he opened it up
and showed that in every organ was an
exact replica of a human anatomy lesson
so the Chinese were
into making really unnaturally real
hyper-real surreal
replicas as well I think the the you
brought you brought up the emotions here
you know we're talking about the uncanny
valley and the and the mixture the
strange mixture of awe and Wonder and
wonders a very important feature of
Greek thought of Greek philosophy
philosophy begins in wonder and and then
yet there's this element of dread or a
bit of horror to it and this to me
connects to them up to my next question
which is that when we think about this
this link between power and otama to
that the bronze bowl that roast people
alive isn't just you know a bowl that
roasts people alive is also a bronze
bowl so there's some way in which power
is using not just the torture device
which inflicts physical suffering but
there's something about controlling the
imagination or controlling our reaction
to similar to things that have similar
to that seems to be part of that gesture
of power that you're really pointing to
in a really interesting way so I just
want to kind of push you a little bit
more to think about what is that if
robots are not just for labor for sex
and for entertainment and therefore
power what is it what how is tyranny
enhanced by the similitude by the fact
that it looks like something that it's
not
well the descriptions of ptolemy ii his
grand procession it gave the impression
that the gods are on his side that that
he could have living images almost
living statues of the gods in in his
parade it it seems to give their
approval to all of his policies and his
reign so i think he was also very
interested in trying to use magnetism
he married his sister and when she died
unexpectedly he made her into a
and he had all these inventors working
on trying to make a statue of this new
goddess that he was going to bring to
Alexandria his sister wife she was going
to be floating in mid-air in a temple
because she would be be a realistic
statue of her and if you see statues of
his wife
they are just shockingly realistic and
sexy and so this statute was going to
hang there in midair with a magnetic
roof and a iron bar inside of the statue
of course that's impossible because of
Earnshaw's law or something it doesn't
happen until electromagnetism but he was
the first to try to use that as would
just show incredible power and convince
people that not only was he a goddess he
declared himself a god he declared his
wife I got us so I think that's part of
the power yeah well I could keep asking
you questions but I suspect there's
gonna be some out there Joe you got
something for me
yes indeed we're first gonna start with
one from our online audience Wow
I know there was an online audience
you mentioned that they were two
examples that were not deadly yes but
never lent examples by someone with
power so I'll talk about the
mythological example that I found when
when Odysseus is trying to get home
after the Trojan War that's what the
Odyssey is all about he's been at the
Trojan War he's a vet of the Trojan War
which lasted ten years he's been
wandering for ten years he can't get
home he wants to get back to his native
island and his family and he meets all
these people that restrain him but near
the end of the book he goes to a
mysteriously advanced society called
facade
and it's run by a king al canuse who
asks asks him his story and Odysseus
says I just want to get home so badly
I'm longing for my wife and the king
says well I'll send you home and one of
my ships I have a fleet of ships that
require no rowers no captains no pilots
no navigators there navigated by thatíll
Don all you need to do is give the ship
your destination and it will devise the
route it's not affected by storm or
currents take you home and return to me
the next day and you can't help but
think of something that's got off this
vast archive of navigational charts of
the known world and it will devise the
route and it has a happy ending
Odysseus gets home nothing bad happens
it's wonderful it's the only story I
know from myth of an automaton that
didn't cause trouble for humans on earth
so that's the mythological example and
the historical example comes from the
4th century BC and the time of Plato in
fact involves a friend of Plato named
arc Titus who was a mechanical engineer
he wrote a lot of treatises they're all
lost unfortunately but we have
quotations from his treatises and they
were described so here's a serious
inventor of mechanical devices and he's
also a statesman in the Greek colony of
Tarentum and he invented the first model
of a bird a realistic model of a bird
that could fly and it flew a few feet or
yards and then had to be reset today's
engineers think that it might have been
steam driven somehow but that's the
first automaton that we know of that
that flu is totally benign and it he was
also according to Aristotle the inventor
of children's toys that were mechanical
one of them was the sort of clacking
thing
that you can buy them now it's a toy
where the the the I can't describe it I
had a slider when I thought of buying
one on Amazon and showing it to you it's
it's a kid's toy that's mechanical
engineer and he made these benign things
just to teach people educate them about
the physics of mechanical engineering so
he was benign and I will point out he
was not a tyrant because he was a
politician in a democracy interesting
great yeah so I have a quick comment and
then a question thanks for teasing out
the question about prometheus I also had
no idea you know the original story and
the original vision of what hope was
which I would as a comment just point
out is pervasive at the moment in our
best example the way we talk about
climate we can't even look at the thing
because we're defending our hope so
there's a there's a a real lesson in
that so thank you my question today even
there was an article in the paper about
a Chinese company that's built a drone
with a machine gun and being able to
sell it like on the market to whoever
wants it and so I'm interested in this
idea that the gods have these things but
it's a problem if it gets down to earth
and so I like my question is what does
that bring up for you either examples of
that problem in the in the in ancient
times or your thoughts about what it
means for today I don't know of any
Greek examples of drone-like entities
but I can hear you sorry my well but for
the recordings I meant more the idea of
the power of these things reaching
outside of those who have power the gods
or the tyrants or the report oh and what
happens when these technologies reach
the masses kind of question yeah
absolutely there I know that in Hindu
mythology gods had really cosmic weapons
that
would rain death from the skies and so
just that whole idea of ambushed or
attacked from the skies there's no
defense for that and it seems like a
godlike power so I don't know what more
to say about it but it's certainly a
frightening development so one question
about you mentioned two automatons one
was the bronze bull the other one I
believe was the image of the wife that
hugs people to death
how are those controlled do we know how
the auto automation worked with the eyes
for the bull and things like that all we
know is about the bronze bull of King
phalaris
the details that we know are the ones
that I gave you the bronze bowls that
were made by her Festus we don't have
any further details except that they
were realistic and they were animated
somehow we know that Hephaestus was a
technician and he he did we do have the
details of the inner workings of of
tellus which is ironic since that's the
oldest example we have of an automaton
and we have the most details about it
and you just have to reap in mind how
much has been lost from antiquity we
only have the texts or fragments that
have survived so much has been lost
and so much artwork has been lost we
learned a lot of details from the
artwork we know that the that tell us
was imagined as a technological being
because of those old vase paintings that
show with Jason using a tool that's very
rare I don't think I don't think there
are very many vase paintings that show
someone using a tool in that way so
there's a lot that's lost we don't
really have the details so firstly I
wanted to thank you because this talk is
such a wonderful example of how
critically important it is that people
study humanities and think about ancient
history and how these disciplines that
we think of as maybe unrelated or
so deeply related when people are just
curious and going back to ancient
science but I have two unrelated
questions the first is sort of because
it's such a prominent topic for now is
whether these automatons and and
automated sort of applications whether
the balance of their benefits to
humanity versus their use in the power
application based on when you're seeing
in history where we have the sparse
examples of their beneficial use and
many examples of their power use and the
second one is yeah is the application
that we talked about which is sex and
whether there were any examples of that
well I can think of some beneficial
machines used in democratic Athens they
had a voting machine and a lottery sort
of a lottery machines so there those
were beneficial and they also had
machines for stagecraft in the theater
they didn't and it's a it's interesting
that the democracy has benign uses of
machines now for for sex and automatons
well first of all there's the story of
Pandora she is made to be an extremely
seductive ravishing young woman and all
of the gods give her attributes as she's
being created so someone gives her
persuasion and another one gives her
buta beauty and Hermes that slide
trickster God he gives her the soul of a
female dog so we don't hear about the
sex between Epimetheus and Pandora she
sort of just disappears after she's
carried out her mission on earth but the
Roman poet Ovid imagined that they did
have sex and that they that she was so
lifelike that she gave birth to a baby
boy and a baby girl which is I think
it's sort of interesting me since that's
sort of the theme of
the second Bladerunner show about
whether or not automata
can automatons become that real and then
of course there's the story of Daedalus
making the artificial cow that was so
realistic he even used the cowhide of
cows that were in a bull the Bulls
pasture he made that artificial cow so
that the Queen pacify who was married to
King Minos the tyrant of Crete she
cursed her husband and we don't know the
reason but she gave him a particularly
diabolical magical spell she was another
witch so that every time he ejaculated
he ejaculated spiders and scorpions so
he was having a hard time in life Zeus
was a patron of King Minos and so he put
a curse on pacify and made her fall in
love with the most magnificent bull in
King Minos herd and so she begged
Daedalus this craftsman to make her a
cow that she could crawl inside and have
sex with the bull and so we have that
story and then we have you want more
Pygmalion the story of Pygmalion you all
know that story right and once again is
a kind of romantic story is supposed to
be romantic
Pygmalion makes this a beautiful statue
of a young woman and prays to the
goddess and she comes alive but if you
read the story it's really creepy I mean
Pygmalion is a guy who hates real women
they're just too real for him and so he
makes his ideal woman a virgin beautiful
and he takes that statute of bed every
night and we have dozens of stories of
men falling in love with realistic
statues from that time period
the Greeks even had a name for it a
gamma philia means statue lust and this
is the uncanny valley right there I mean
these guys would sneak into temples at
night and have sex with especially
statues of Aphrodite because they were
particularly beautiful and leave
evidence of their shocking crimes to be
found in the morning so now I should
have given a trigger warning for that
the more things change we had another
question for you
thank you for your presentation this may
be a little bit more serious yes I'm
ready
another myth specifically being you know
Prometheus constructing man out of clay
yes and I wonder how your reading of
these myths of automata might be reread
considering the human as potential first
automaton on the other side of that of
course recognizing that these gods are
something created and you could yeah you
could bring in your concept of power the
importance of power in that as well as
you want absolutely uh that's a
philosophical question and this this
picture that's up here right now is
Prometheus building the first human from
scratch he's starting with the framework
he's starting with the skeleton as the
framework and then he'll add the flesh
and the sinew and all the organs and
he's using tools to do it so are we all
just puppets of God that's and I think
Plato was maybe one of the first to
bring that question up in one of his
dialogues he says let's imagine that
we're all just puppets of God's superior
beings so yeah I think that's a
certainly shows power so my question
relates to a giant stories are not only
about history they usually also entail
some sort of educational purpose and
have a moral sub line or subtext but any
references from these ancient authors
that said tell us how Jerry with this
how to live with it how to deal with it
actually how did you react to it shall
we now destroy our technology to be more
or less try to technology to the masses
or what's what's the lesson to be
learned from the perspective maybe of
yeah the author's the that's an an
interesting question it makes me think
of Aristotle who knew all these myths of
course and he was justifying slavery in
one of his treatises and it's it's a
really bad defense of slavery everyone
agrees that it doesn't have a very
National Defense of slavery but right in
the middle of his defense of slavery
that Athenians had a lot of slaves he
just goes off on to this thought
experiment and says well now what if we
had automatons like Hephaestus made for
the gods what if we had looms that could
weave on their own what if we had
instruments musical instruments that
could play themselves well we wouldn't
need slaves and and then he just drops
it and goes back
why didn't he continue that train of
thought that would have been quite
interesting but at least he's musing on
the economic and social ramifications of
automatons imagining and trying to think
what would happen if we had them here in
Athens and the fact that he put it in
writing even though he dropped this drop
the thought and didn't continue it the
fact that he put it in writing makes me
think that maybe that was a topic of
conversation among philosophers and we
just had that scrap of a hint one more
question
thank you for that fabulous presentation
thank you my question is actually could
you give us a few more examples it's
explaining the East Asia China India etc
and do they precede the examples that
you've given us from Europe and Egypt
and are they of the same
primarily use of power to exercise
tyranny or do they have other purposes
that's a good question and people ask if
maybe Greece was the it was unique and I
don't think I don't think they were it's
just that we have a lot of information
and I particularly don't don't I don't
study India or China but I did find
examples and one of my favorites is you
and I were discussing this there was a
legend that comes from India from the
time of we don't know the exact date of
this legend it comes from a text that is
the first written text of oral legends
so they could be very old the text
itself is from something like second
century BC to first century AD something
like that but the stories are much older
and it's from it's in the language of
Burma Sanskrit and Chinese so it's
really deep in the East and it concerns
a crew of robotic warriors that defended
the relics of Buddha after he died and
according to the story when Buddha died
his bodily remains were hidden under a
stupa in a secret chamber and guarded by
these robot warriors and they were said
to spin so fast that they would chop up
anyone who
came near them and these were set in
place by King I'm not gonna pronounce
this correctly agita sutra satra or
sutra and these were to remain in place
guarding Buddha's relics until King
Ashoka would come and defeat them or
disable them somehow and then distribute
the relics of Buddha we know that he did
that so it's a very interesting legend
and in the legend the plans for the
robots came from Alexandria the Silicon
Valley of the West they were stolen by
an engineer in India who traveled there
specifically to learn how to make them
and he brought the plans he some house
either sewed the plans under his skin or
tattooed them onto his body no no one
was really sure about the translation
and he knew that these robot makers it's
very interesting the way they describe
the West the robot makers are not
allowed to reveal their secrets of
making robots in the in the West they in
fact there are assassin robots that will
chase them down and kill them if they
try to tell their secrets so he knew his
body would never get back to India but
he told his son where he had hidden the
plans and sure enough the robot
assassins killed him on the way back to
India and his son brings the plans so I
mean it's a very complicated story but
it doesn't really have any tyrants it's
a it's a beneficial use of those robots
yeah but if industrial espionage there
so that's that's it for the evening at
8:00 adrienne is gonna be signing her
books and i highly encourage you to read
it it's very entertaining and very
illuminating there's also a lot of
details about actual engineering that
she touched on tonight but there's a lot
more about what people were actually
doing as well as the mythologies that
you vaguely remember from your youth and
now realise they're more interesting
or so so we'll be will be doing that and
we ask people to clear out of this space
so we can move the chairs out of the way
and please put your glasses back to the
bar if you're done with your drinks and
there is another event coming up with
that I do not have in my brain so
someone else is going to help me with
have to help you with that one
what's it Andrew McAfee at the 18th and
that's ed at the s of Jesse on the 18th
so come and check that out
thanks again
[Applause]
[Music]